tut mir leid ich wollte euch gestern
abend verderben
ich fand es echt lustig was deine mutter
so erzählt hat vor allem die geschichte
wie du mit dem brausepulver in der
tasche den bach gefallen wissen
das war wirklich dramatisch
ich hatte mein ganzes taschengeld dafür
ausgegeben dann hat sich alles anschauen
aufgelöst oder die geschichte von deinen
reiterferien auf dem bau meine mutter
ist sowieso nicht ständig so ein
bisschen besser kennen zu lernen
entschuldigung ich habe mir was du dich
mein alter rechner
der ist vielleicht ich bin der
schnellste aber dafür ist bei denen die
stimmen darunter fällt
knast ausgesucht
ihr kopf ist das nicht ein toller
ausblick
vielleicht könnte man hier ein festzelt
aufbauen
dann können die gäste den schiffen zu
sehen während die cocktails trinken
dafür bekomme ich nie mit genehmigung
wegen des caterings habe ich mit dem
besitzer von dem restaurant da
gesprochen
das ist doch viel zu schickimicki sie
brauchen etwas bodenständigere
man könnte vielleicht einen ausdruck
schiff mieten wir fahren von düsseldorf
nach köln und den uns den ton an
die company sitzt in köln
wenn dann wollen die andersrum fahren
aber wer will schon von köln nach
düsseldorf
man das tut mir leid aber wir haben
einen auftritt endlich mal wieder und
wir mussten kurzfristig problem als
hätte ich denn tun sollen
die probe absage und die anderen hängen
lassen
nein es geht nicht stattdessen heißt
mädchen lassen sich alles so gefreut
dich kennenzulernen
alex was ich muss noch den zug nach köln
kriegen ist spät
ich weiß aber wir müssen das angebot
heute noch fertig kriegen und wir haben
immer noch keine location wenn man an
staub allergie hat dann müsste man noch
die ganze zeit überwiesen oder ich mein
ist es doch überall staub bist du hast
du aber könnte mitbewohner ganz allein
ich verstehe es ja auch sie sind dann
ständig da jetzt nicht jedenfalls keine
lust mehr zu warten wenn ich immer etwas
essen gehen
weißt du was von gestern alles noch
übrig geblieben ist
wir essen hier müssen die ja nach hause
kommen ok
warum darf ich sie nicht sehen was du
dann nicht wenn es nichts schlimmes ist
dann kannst du es mir auch ruhig zeigen
so nervt mich nicht du arbeitest hier
du bist nicht meine mutter